enough about our hostilities let's move
on to the industry at large the first
Oscar to be tossed out in the current
series will be done gently by a lady who
is the first-time nominee in pictures
and an all-time favorite of the Broadway
stage miss Carol Channing right here
thank you Bob
thank you it's my privilege to present
the award for the best achievement in
sound and what a thrill it is for me to
fondle an Oscar even in transit the
nominations are do I get an info oh
thank you
the nominations are right there cameras
Warner Brothers seven art studio sound
Department the Dirty Dozen
metro-goldwyn-mayer studio sound
department dr. dolittle 20th Century Fox
studio sound department in the heat of
the night Samuel Goldwyn studio sound
department Thoroughly Modern Millie
Universal City Studios sound department
now the envelope thank you
the winner is Samuel Goldwyn studio
sound department for in the heat of the
night
accepter for Samuel Goldwyn studio sound
department mr. Courtney Sawyer sound
director
I wish to thank the Academy members on
behalf of the Samuel Goldwyn sound
department and I particularly would like
to thank the boys that worked on this
thing especially Walter Gossett with
production mixture and Klem important
our recording mixer thank you very much